first uh so we're gonna do a point flip
out here
yeah we're gonna flip out here instead
of doing it all right so
[Music]
so you're
[Music]
[Music]
i have no preference but you want to
just go first you want to go first
yeah okay okay so before we start i just
want to put on some guidelines
to make sure this debate is respectful
we want to keep it respectful no insults
toward
each other we want to make sure we don't
go outside of the outline
of the heathen trinity we're gonna keep
it within the guy that time
if anyone over steps i will cut them off
okay this goes for both speakers and
each speaker we've got three warnings
after the three mornings we will if you
have let's say you're in your eight
minute rebuttal
and you've had your third warning we're
going to cut off that eight-minute rebel
that's it there's not going to be any
continuation to that
so that's that's the guidelines that
we're going to be putting up you know
of course you have each one of you have
20 minute open
statements 12-minute first rebuttals
8-minute second rebuttals then you have
crossfire examinations where each of you
are gonna ask six questions each okay
it's gonna be one question one question
and two minutes to respond to that
question and then you're gonna have your
closing statements five minutes each
and then in the end there's gonna be a q
a uh basically we're gonna form two
lines one
line that's gonna be asking new
questions one line's gonna be asking uh
uh enough questions just in case so we
don't want someone to bombard
like a certain individual question so
both of you can get the fair share of
questions so
have any understood all good good you
can shake hands if you want
that's all right all right sure uh so
oh yeah you can actually go inside your
dressing room